So how do we do recognition?
Well, actually it's
pretty straightforward.
I have some new novel x comes in,
some new novel face image.
All right?
All I do is I project
it into the subspace.
What does that mean?
Just like before.
I subtract off the means and
I compute the dot product,
the coefficients W1 through Wk.
By the way, I can then do something
that's optional put here.
Supposed I'm not really sure that
what you gave me was a face image.
Well, what I can do is, I could
reconstruct using those coefficients.
And now here's the thing.
If you gave me some other 10,000
dimensional vector, right?
You know, three guys on a bicycle.
And I try to make that image
by just summing up a hundred
eigenvectors from the face space.
How well do you think I can
reconstruct that image?
Not so well.
The only images I can
reconstruct well are faces.
So I could do the reconstruction and
compare them and say, aha, bad choice.
This is not a face image.
It also means, by the way,
if I'm looking for
faces in a picture, I might do that.
In fact, in the original, Turk and
Pentland, they actually
did detection that way.
There are now better ways to
just detect raw faces, but
the ability to reconstruct is
a way of knowing that yep,
I actually have what I was looking for.
I'm going to use, to see if I can
restructure, do some tracking, but
hang on, that's for,
that's for the next lecture.
But for the recognition part,
it's optional.
Let's assume it really is a face.
Well, then, all we can do is,
we can say, all right.
You gave me these W's, right?
1 through k.
Let me find in my list, the one that's
closest in of, of those k numbers.
I might use a Euclidean distance, some
other distance metric, but basically,
I have a description of
a new face coming in, and
I just see which of the descriptions
in my database is closest.
And that's why you can think of this
somewhat as a generative model.
There, there's actually more detail to
use it in a more probabilistic way.
We'll actually talk a little
bit about that in the tracking.
But the idea is that,
each one of these descriptions
gives me a probability if you will.
Or likelihood of what this
person's face might look like,
because it assumes that this has
captured most of the variation, and it,
the other stuff doesn't matter too much.
And if I, if a new one comes in,
I can just compare them.
And if I get closer, that's more likely,
and that's why it's a generative model.